so how do the profits I Stanford
University no original and the
prototypical network economics and I
think you're gonna get her to hook up on
welcome me some food she go so another
thing this when I knew to today is this
beautiful data set here is parameters of
connected and even though with the 70
villages in India and we want to educate
social in collections and it is an
excellent not standing beautiful thanks
ashish so so this is joint work with a
rune and following up on the talk he
gave up earlier this morning and i
started with just a quote from jacob
moreno and Helen Paul Jennings you know
making emphasizing the point that that
we're really interested in
interdependencies in network formation
and that's an important part of social
aspects and and we need to deal with
that I don't know if people really know
this but I was just talking to Michael
about this Marino actually was the first
person to start doing social network
analysis in a meaningful way and was the
first sochi graham what came from 1932
this is a mapping of interconnections
friendship networks in columbia
university i think in various halls and
he was interested in trying to figure
out what the right real Hall should be
so he's doing sort of clustering before
anyone was doing clustering but that's
fun tidbit of knowledge but basically
what you know the point here is that
there's a lot of interconnections
between these relationships the
dependencies are essential and and we
need estimate models to deal with these
and the kinds of questions you know that
arise are you more likely to link to
friends of friends do relationships need
to be embedded in certain structures to
function so when we actually look at
things like favor exchange and some of
the villages that she was referring to
having friends in common becomes an
important aspect of making sure that you
actually abide by the kinds of
agreements and the reciprocity that are
expected under social norms so there's
reasons to believe that you need certain
kinds of structure
is in order to make societies function
and you know do you want to link to
others who are well connected is that
something that that's desirable to get
information and so forth so these kinds
of things mean that there's going to be
dependencies that we need somehow to
take advantage of and I'll talk about
the the data set that Ashish was
referring to a little bit so we
basically have 75 different villages of
data this is a picture of village 26 and
this is a kerosene rice network and
basically nodes here are households and
link between them means that they share
kerosene and rice of between the
households and in particular one thing
that you notice here there's an enormous
amount of foam awfully so these are
color coded by by caste designation and
in particular blue or what are called
Scheduled Castes and Scheduled Tribes so
is actually sits like 53 different
castes and the villages and this is just
a broad cut in two so Scheduled Castes
and Scheduled Tribes or the affirmative
action casts recognized by the Union
Government and then the red are general
and otherwise backward castes and one
thing you begin to notice is that the
problem you know the frequency of links
within is is a little more than ten
times higher than the frequency of links
across and and so that gives you an idea
that there's substantial homophily here
you know we could begin to model this by
a block model but what we're interested
in is understanding whether there's
specific patterns to these kinds of
links and one question you you might
begin to you know there's a social
scientists we're interested in in
particular that brings these linked
dependencies to the forefront is when we
look at people from different castes is
it are we more likely to see these kinds
of relationships and situations whether
in isolation or would you also see them
when they have friends in common okay so
would it be social pressures that would
mean that you're more likely to be to do
this if if nobody else is witnessing it
or if it's not conspicuous then if you
have this embedded in a triangle and so
what we'd like to do is have
models that begin to allow us to answer
this kind of question and a straight
block model won't give us the ability to
answer that question directly okay so
what we're going to do is you know
starting from social scientific
questions we want models that allow us
to test for specific theories of graph
formation we want those to be Cove area
based sub graph based and another thing
we want is we want models that can
predict out-of-sample and so the models
should also be ones you know it
ultimately why would you be interested
in these kinds of things you're going to
be interested because you might want to
be instituting a policy that increases
interaction and sharing across across
groups or information transmission or
something and if you want to do that
then you want to be able to understand
what's making the network look like it
does and how would you change that and
so you need models that you can begin to
figure out which parameters you might
affect and how that might change the
network structures so you need
generative models that you can go and do
counterfactual kinds of exercises with
okay so that's sort of just a big
picture of what we're after and then
this will bring us back to the bottles
that Arun was talking about earlier this
morning okay so what we're going to look
at is a class of models that we've
called subgraph generation models where
effectively what we think of as the
building block is not the network itself
but the building blocks are the are just
formations of different sub graph
structures and no sub graph structures
might serve specific social goals or
aims it might be beneficial for certain
reasons and those things are going to be
the building blocks so we'll just work
directly at with those things as in
statistics and the graph is sort of an
incidental thing which is generated so
people are forming links triangles other
kinds of things isolates and the
networks are basically gonna be a
byproduct okay so so let me just review
in case I mean the people you know
things go by quickly in 20 minute talk
so I just want to make sure that we
understand exactly what these sub graph
generation models look like and then
I'll apply some of them to the Union
data so nature or people in these cases
are going to be forming different kinds
of sub graphs so it might be some sub
graph of type j and there's going to be
a statistic which just counts in our
population that we have observed how
many of those things did we actually see
okay and these things may intersect and
overlap and we observe this resulting
network and we in trying to infer the
probabilities of these different objects
being formed and then those things will
inform us allow us to test hypotheses
about the cross cast kinds of things and
so forth so when you say the network the
byproduct is at the end of the day going
to be interested making claims by these
very local information do not exactly
exactly so so we're interested in
understanding you know we're interested
in in well yeah so we're going to be
interested basically in the local
structures that emerge and try and
understand is it more likely that people
going to be embedded in these triangles
or links and so forth and so we want
models that allow us to test those kinds
of things they'll generate networks for
us and so we can talk about general
network properties and they'll generate
things we can do path length
calculations drag component calculations
and so forth but those are all going to
be incidentals and not the primitives
that will work with and so it will still
be interested it doesn't mean to say
we're not interested in the network
structures generally it just means that
those are going to be incidental to the
structures not the the generative
underlying pieces okay so just as an
example just to bring back to reiterate
what Arun talked about so we have these
nodes people can meet in triples and
they might they meet randomly and they
decide whether to form these these
relationships some triangles form people
can also form bilateral relationships
some of those emerge and then you know
the part in terms of estimation of the
model is as these things can confound
each other because you can get some
overlaps and and so forth and so then
the estimation problem is just inferring
what these different probabilities were
from from the actual data and as a room
pointed out when things are sparse
enough this is going to happen
relatively infrequently and so doing
direct counts of the actual objects of
triangles and links and so forth allows
you then to go back and really
understand and recover what the relative
frequencies and probabilities are okay
so that's the basic idea of these kinds
of models and so what we see is the
resulting network and we don't know that
this triangle
actually generated actually is a link
and edges of other triangles but that
happens relatively infrequently and so
the estimation can go through their way
in which we could think about it a
generally I know it's in the sense they
get an awareness of what ties are making
exactly so I'm going to go I'm going to
come to that and effectively what's
going to happen is is these
probabilities are going to come from
from the choices of the individuals and
so one thing that we want to understand
is you know do we feel this social
pressure so is there a different benefit
that I get from forming a link across
casts if there's somebody else sees me
then if I don't and so will my question
on that point is how much is in our head
it's hard on my really past about that
am I where they bittar someone consider
that yeah so uh you know I guess in
general as social scientists we don't
what we some people do look in people's
heads I there are neuro scientists who
are literally trying to figure out
exactly what's going on in people's
heads but at this level we're not going
to be able to look in people's heads
what we're going to be able to do is as
if kinds of so we'll be able to
calculate look if we infer that people
are doing things that are beneficial for
them and tend not to do things that
aren't beneficial then we can can
recover some preference relationships
from the data but whether or not that's
actually what people thought of
explicitly whether they're calculating
in these things and I think the story in
terms of strategic models is more an as
if story in the sense that over time if
there's relationships that I that
somehow aren't don't feel good to me I
drop them and if there are ones that
seem beneficial I add them whether
people are calculating in a in a cold
hard way it's not so obvious I mean the
reason becomes relevant is then we
should think about funk functionality of
a network being created and how much of
the
you are aware of us they're creating
great right yeah yeah yeah and here that
they don't have to be able to to assess
local patterns and benefits and cost of
those things okay so one one thing just
to start out the subgraph generation
models we can view as statistical
exponential random graph models a point
that Arun pointed to earlier and that
turns out to be useful so so one is just
a very easy theorem on the subgraph
generation models so if you if you work
in a world where the world throws down
different types of objects sub graphs
and possibly with covariates and so
forth and what you do is is now you keep
track of all the statistics and then a
bunch of parameters on those statistics
if you look at that model and look at
the probability that a given type of
statistic or sub graph is generated and
you did a fairly naive calculation which
is you just set the parameter you set a
parameter equal to the log odds ratio of
that object being present to not being
present and you counted possible
statistics by looking at how many you
got out of how many were possible and
just did a choose operation so a simple
binomial calculation then the
probability of the actual statistics
coming out has this exponential random
graph model formulation so the
exponential family actually is is a
representation of this if you can
observe the true counts of all these sub
graphs okay so the problem is that that
that that link we're going to have some
bias in the sense that you're actually
not going to observe exactly how many
links were generated and how many
triangles you're going to have to
estimate that but if you could see you
exactly what those are then it would fit
exactly into the exponential family and
why is the exponential family so nice
it's probably one of the most studied
sets of distributions we know a lot of
things about it the convergence
properties or all kinds of things are
very easy to work with here and and so
this gives us some nice mathematics
behind these things and you can you know
prove things about these kinds of this
family you can also prove them directly
using different by you
calculations okay so that's just sort of
you know so there's a bunch of theorems
we have in the paper about the
relationship between these different
kinds of models okay so I want to do two
to two illustrations of these things so
first of all you know what's a useful of
these things and what do they add beyond
block models to the data and you know
then why what can we use in terms of
preference based models and strategic
bottles and how can they help us out
okay so we're going to do is you use
these data from the 75 Indian villages
you can find these via my website you
can find them via runes website so the
data are we have 75 different villages
where we went in and basically now we
have pretty much a census of all the
network we have 13 different types of
networks to borrowing and lending
kerosene rice money who do you go to for
advice who comes to visit your house
there's all kinds of different
relationships so there's lots of data
there and what we're going to do is
let's estimate a model and then use it
to generate networks okay so this is
just a question of suppose we used a
block model and generate networks back
do they look like the real networks
suppose we use one of these sub graph
generation models estimate it then use
it to generate networks and see what we
get back ok now the pure exponential
random graph models you can't do
directly because you can't estimate them
as a room pointed out this morning but
you can estimate this family of them
using the sub graphs directly ok so what
we want to do is how well do the model
recreate the networks but especially on
non model characteristics right so
obviously if you're fitting these things
directly to certain characteristics they
should do fairly well but is the
question is do they get other aspects of
the networks that we didn't put into the
models they extra those fairly well ok
so what we're going to do is we're going
to estimate a subgraph generation model
on covariance allowing for triangle
counts and then we'll also do sort of a
standard link-based block model based on
the covariance so here the covariance
the main covariance we're going to use
our GPS data and cast data but you can
put in a lot more and basically the
pictures that look pretty much the same
okay so what do we do so here's the
actual data a bunch of different things
that we might be interested in that work
so how many triangles are there how many
unsupported links so links that aren't
in triangles what's the average degree
how many isolated nodes are there what's
the coefficient clustering coefficient
what's the fraction of links sorry nodes
in the giant component what's the first
eigenvalue of the adjacency matrix
what's the second eigenvalue of the
stochastic sized adjacency matrix this
is a measure of the best cut in the
graph or a homophily cut what's the
average path length and so forth okay so
you've got a whole series of different
things and basically what we're doing is
if you look at fitting a link based
block model what it's going to be
matching on is is really degree right so
it should nail degree fairly well
because you're just getting you're
trying to get link frequencies and so
it's gotta hit that right on and indeed
it's going to match the data exactly on
average degree now the subject
generation model what it's doing is
basically counting links and triangles
it'll get triangles and and unsupported
links well it overestimates degree a
little bit both of them do pretty poorly
figuring out how many isolates there
should be so what happens is in these
kinds of villages you tend to have some
people who are just a social for
whatever reason don't you know for
actually person reasons aren't
interacting with other individuals and
so if you just fit the model directly
you don't pick up enough of them and so
what you can do is you can throw in
isolates into the sub graph model too
and if you do that you come a little
closer on that but here you know you
pick up pretty well these kinds of
statistics but then the question is you
know how well do you do on the other
things and the kinds of things are you
going to pick up not surprisingly
clustering is going to be a lot better
under these class of models because
you're putting in triangles explicitly
so you're going to match clustering much
much better and then when you go into
fractions of the giant component or
first eigenvalue second eigenvalue and
so forth you know you basically end up
doing
better in these cases at matching some
of the things and I can just sort of go
through so here's the actual data is in
gray here this is the CDF of the degree
distribution sort of averaged across all
the villages and then what you can get
is if you do the sub graph generation
model you get this blue line which
actually doesn't match the average as
well but matches the CDF more closely
than what you actually get out of the
block model is it 70 or some villages
yeah and they all have roughly the same
number of nodes you put up order hundred
or something then CH yeah this roughly
200 households per village no they're
fairly separate so they're about 40
kilometers apart mostly there's very so
part of the reason we went to these
villages they're very rural it was part
of a microfinance diffusion experiment
that that we were involved with so these
are fairly isolated rural villages
there's some occasional intermarriages
between these but the relatively little
interaction among the village so you can
really treat these as more or less 75
different populations yeah so the block
here is not leighton bloch models but
this has explicit blocks based on the
covariance so what we do is we allow the
we just look at observable covariance
and then fit the so this is more of this
the sociology term of block model that
has become used in statistics so it's
not late in space but it's really the
original block models going back to the
1960s from the sociology literature so
so here we're fitting it based on
observed characteristics but we have a
lot of observed characteristics so so
you can see pretty much you know we know
that people's age profession their
castes there some measures of wealth
level how many people are in the
households GPS data so we have a lot of
information about the individuals to
work on so basically what what we do in
the blot in this sub graph generation
model is we're adding triangles so the
parameter count goes up because we're
adding triangles yes so so let's see we
have get it exactly so we have 0 so the
versions in these graph are
for for the block model and six for the
soo gyum yeah so they're both relatively
small compared to the number of villages
you know when you see the clustering
then obviously this sub graph generation
model is going to match clustering
distributions much better because the
block model just doesn't produce
triangles right so so it's rare that you
get triangles unless you even when
you're generating fairly small blocks so
if you begin to look at you know here's
the clustering 75 village worth and what
we do is we also have an algorithm for
estimating exactly how many overlaps
there might be so the theorem sort of
says asymptotically you don't have to
worry about overlap and finite samples
you can't have overlap probabilities and
so you can do a finite set correct you
know correction for that we have an
algorithm for doing that and in that
puts you a little closer but so here's
where the sub graph generation models in
the block models obviously miss the
clustering if you begin to look at the
first eigen values you know these models
recreate the first eigen values better
than the new tend to get from from block
models if you look at the second
eigenvalue of the stochastic size matrix
all the data tends to be the numbers are
extremely high so these are very very
segregated networks so when you look at
these villages the cast really cuts
across these villages and so you tend to
have really high second eigen values of
this matrix so that means that you know
that there's going to be a cut almost
where you can you can divide things in
with extremely low connectivity across
and here the block models just don't
pick that up okay so so one thing is you
know isolates it's not doing so well if
you add throw a nice lets you do better
so basically what that does just shows
as you know adding these extra sub graph
structures allows us to recreate
structures of the network with a fairly
simple model so we're just throwing into
triangles and yet that helps us pick up
a lot of other things that we're going
network it in terms of observations
question I mean it's not capturing the
cluster instruction you want to leave or
you want a mixed-effects default model
where you have some code or a base blog
sense of layton blocks right so so here
we're pretty sure that the reason it's
not picking up the clustering is not
because there's latent things that are
going on but because it's it's
explicitly not accounting for the
dependency right so the block model is
that there's a dependency that's going
on it's that's it more than the block
level and it's and I think one of the
stories that the dependency is going on
there's sort of two stories that they go
on in these one is that actually having
friends in common helps enforce behavior
so if I'm borrowing and lending having a
friend in common actually helps me
execute that and so there's going to be
a tendency to try and complete two stars
so so it's it's it's saying that there's
a there's actually a reason for having
those things that's not going to be
picked up by a block model regulated so
so put them in the same block and what
I'm saying is even if you put it in the
same block there's going to be more that
once I put in so generally if I put
people in the same block but suppose it
was a block here and I still think that
within block links are formed
independently so if two people are
sitting in a situation like this and
there's another two people that are
sitting in a situation like this the
probability of this is going to be the
same as the probability of this link
within a block right once I've uncovered
the latent block as well and the claim
i'm making is that this you're going to
tend to see them with higher probability
conditional on the structure even
conditional on the block structure so
given all the characteristics that are
determining these things you're still
going to see these these extra
correlations and they're there for a
particular reason which is that helps
people actually transact if they have
people in common I mean that's the basic
point
okay so let's talk quickly at the end
now about these cast relationships are
they more likely to occur in private
with no friends in common or do you see
with them with the same frequency across
embedded relationships and this will get
to what Dana's question was so you know
our will start to put preferences on
these individuals and explicitly model
why they might be forming wings and so
let's think of a situation on we've got
these characteristics of a given
individual and the individual is going
to get some benefit from having say a
link but if they have characteristic sex
I and the person they're linking to has
characteristics XJ so there's some
benefit of actually having this
transaction so this is somebody else who
has similar needs for kerosene I'm going
to be able to borrow online kerosene
that's worth a certain amount to me if
they're if they're very different from
me maybe I don't have the same value and
so forth so there's actually a value
which depends explicitly on this okay
and there's some distribution of the the
error term here and what we're going to
do is then the probability that a link
is going to form is going to be
proportional to the distribution so if
I'm looking at this error term as long
as the error term is less actually sure
there should be a minus here but so so
I'm going to look at the the value of
the actual utility to one person the
value of the utilities another person I
perturb those utilities and the
probability that a link forms is going
to be the probability that the first
person finds it attractive time is the
probability that the second person forms
at a track finds attractive right so we
only form these if we both find the
relationship attractive it's a mutual
consent situation okay when we go to a
triangle then we're going to have three
people involved and so you're going to
have a basically a cube of the
probabilities that they're each going to
find it attractive right so it's going
to scale slightly differently and that's
going to give you a slightly different
probability of forming triangles and
forming links so links taken sense of
two people triangles take consent of
three people so you're going to have to
you know the error term is going to be
cubed here instead of squared
okay so now if we have a null hypothesis
that the probability that I prefer a
good cross cast triad to the probability
i prefer within past triad is the same
as the probability that i prefer a cross
cast link then within cast link right so
so what we're doing is not just testing
that hypothesis that I somehow feel more
conspicuous so the the alternative
hypothesis is that this one is going to
be less right so I'm going to feel less
likely to want to form these things if
I'm involved in a situation where other
people are present but now what we have
to do is control for the fact that these
things involved three consents otherwise
that's going to drive this naturally
down so we want to control for the fact
that that there's going to be less
prevalent just because there's three
people involved than two okay so what
this thing looks like is the cube of
this probability that i want to that i
find it beneficial and this is the
square and so what we're going to end up
with is the probability that you prefer
to form cross cast triads is going to
look like the frequency counts to the
third and this want to look like to the
half okay and that corrects for the bias
that you're naturally going to find
otherwise it would look like the
triangles or less prevalent already okay
so then if you plot the 75 villages and
you know here basically on the 45 degree
line if we look at the link relative
link frequencies down here from a cross
cast compared the same and then do the
triangles here they would be on lining
up on the 45 degree line if if you ended
up with it under the null hypothesis and
the alternative hypothesis they should
be below and indeed you know the
fraction of them are below if you do a
simple test of this you need you know
that the ninety-nine point nine percent
level that you reject the null and in
particular what's interesting is so what
we did here is divided the villages into
two categories those where the villages
are fairly balanced in terms of cast so
if you look at the the upper castes and
the lower castes that there's a fairly
even
balance and then the light blue ones are
ones where you have fairly balanced ones
and the red ones are ones where the
smaller cast is actually a fairly small
minority so what we do is we look at the
ratio of the bigger cast to the smaller
cast and then cut that at the median and
the light blue ones are ones where you
have a fairly balanced ratio and the red
ones where you have an imbalanced ratio
and the more balanced the ratio the more
segments of the society has become and
the more you see that these triangles
are less prevalent compared to the links
whereas if you if you look at the
situation where you've got the fairly
small minorities they integrate better
and that's something you find in
homophily fairly generally when you look
across things that you see things
segments much more when you've got even
sized groups that when you have lopsided
sized groups okay so you know reject the
null hypothesis based on the model
people show us is statistically
significantly stronger preference I mean
obviously this is all model inference so
let me just sort of summarize main
points to take away from this then so
the exponential random graph models as a
ruin alluded to this morning face
estimation challenges and there's no
general results on consistency the block
models are quite useful in terms of
estimation but they miss dependencies
that are needed to test some particular
social theories where we explicitly are
thinking that people are conditioning on
unobservable traits and are forming
subgraphs based on those traits and what
we're doing is working with statistics
or sub graphs rather than networks that
simplifies things substantially so these
classes of models are estimable and have
these dependencies in them and then we
get consistency fast estimation and then
what you can do is you can actually use
these things to generate networks to
look with these you know test hypotheses
and then do alternative kinds of things
as well so there's a bunch of stuff in
the paper that we didn't talk about here
you can do multiplexing you know we're
more likely to to borrow and lend money
with each other if we do kerosene and so
forth
so there's a lot of that in there too so
I should stop